dix ans que j'ai très peu de chances de
survivre si j'attrape pas quelque chose
pour ma grippe et donc je prends le plus
grand en me disant que je vais pouvoir
monter dessus et sauf que je peux pas
donc je reste juste à gripper c'est la
nuit en plus rares la nuit alors en plus
vers l'est comment il ya des il ya des
requins en plus dans le oui oh là là
dedans mais c'est
donc vous restez 10 heures seul dans
l'eau vous êtes petite fille de 12 ans
quand même 13 maintenant ça c'est dur
déroulés la nuit j'étais consciente
qu'il y avait un accident parce que
j'entendais aussi des femmes autour de
moi appeler à l'aide
à l'aide aussi comme elle est à force
avec la fatigue etc je me suis endormi
en fait sur mon déprédations donc quand
je me réveille le lendemain matin je
suis un peu dans un des lieux où je me
dis ou tomber arrivé sauf moi donc je
m'accroche à cette idée là où ma mère
forcément est arrivé et je me dis mais
elle doit être tellement paniquée
puisqu'elle était tellement protectrice
avec ses enfants il faut que je
m'accroche pour pouvoir la retrouver